my question is for both of you and it's
if you'd known how successful and what a
phenomenal your work was going to be is
there anything you would have done
differently I would have no I would have
done all my promotions for Game of
Thrones in a in a disguise series is
great but the being a celebrity is
something that I have mixed feelings
about the loss of privacy and and I
don't know the headline says they drive
me a little nuts it's it never ceases to
be surreal the you know what the the
success of series has brought me you
know those who follow my blog now I'm a
big fan of American football and the New
York Giants and the New York Jets now
the two teams I follow and like any
football fan I'm a little crazy when it
comes to my team and you know I'm always
saying you know murder the other team
you know kill that guy ah fire happy the
bomb you know that's what friends do you
know nobody ever took us seriously until
I became famous and then suddenly you
know Game of Thrones created holes for
Jets coach to be fired it's appearing as
a headline in the New York Daily News
what the hell
we had other guy in the crowd here I
chose the general manager not the coach
I love to coach jet the Jets coach Rex
Ryan he's great so that's why I did I'd
be anonymous
I'd be JD Salinger somebody nobody would
know I look good no I wouldn't be jay-z
soldier because I want the focus to be
polish while I'm alive so I'd be I don't
know who's a famous writer that nobody
knows what he looks like but he's where
everybody knows what everybody looks
like yeah wait wait I did see a very
good double for you so I think maybe we
should just employ him and send him out
into the world actually how excellent go
for that we're talking about all the
uniforms over the weekend and I just
wonder if you you've now got your own
style you have your your lovely
waistcoat and you usually have your cap
do you find that it is a sort of author
uniform I I it's surreal that you know
that I've had got a uniform or something
I've never I've never thought about that
but now I'm sold as a Halloween costume
I'm not even making that up as funny
they'd actually last Halloween you could
you could buy also the Game of Thrones
costumes you could come as Jon Snow or
Daenerys or me which was very odd and
when I go to conventions to the United
States there are always cosplayers about
you see there are some credible
cosplayers here I have you you guys been
seeing them and enjoying them amazing
amazing stuff
and I'd love to see you know King Robert
or Jon Snow or Daenerys or Sansa
cosplayers going around but I also run
into me as players some of whom look
more like me than I do and that's that's
kind of scary
what does that really boggle me frankly
are not the parodies at a show or
anything having to do with the show but
the ones that are about me personally
you know at the San Diego Comic Con
there was one guy selling a george RR
martin doll which was pretty freaky I'm
not sure how I feel about that I think
so my well-beloved fans are probably
using it for voodoo purposes are you
comfortable with being so enormous ly
famous and in demand I'm trying to fight
what isn't in a piece have you know I
haven't we came to the Fringe Festival
like just three four years ago and one
or two people recognized me the whole
week that we were here now I walk the
streets and and three or four people
recognized me every block and it's it's
transformed my life in ways that I'm not
entirely comfortable with